hallo wir sind heute in polen genau
genommen in ostrow wielkopolski das ist
eine kleinstadt in der mitte holen
wir sind am vierten lithium frederic
chopin konrad hat uns in dieser stadt
eingeladen konrad warum lernst du
deutsch weil das mein hobby ist okay es
ist sehr kalt
deshalb gehen wir jetzt rein
jetzt sind wir im eingang der schule im
treppenhaus
die schüler gehen die treppe hoch wie
sehen wir glücklich aus denn sie gehen
in die schule
im flur der schule wie im 3 slangen
die europäische flagge die polnische
flagge und die flagge der stadt ostrow
wielkopolski wir haben frau jahren drauf
getroffen
sie ist die direktorin der schule bei
ihrem druck wie viele schüler gibt es an
der schule an der schule haben wir in
diesem jahr über 300 aus 370 schüler
hier sind wir auf dem flur auf dem flur
gibt es verschiedene bilder
es gibt stühle und eine vitrine monika
was ist das da wind um sehr pokale
diese pokale hat die schule gewonnen
darf in die pokale
monika hast du auch einen pokal gewonnen
nein
schade
jetzt sind wir hier mit der zweiten
gruppe wir haben gerade die 1000 schüler
spielen auf dem flur
jetzt sind wir vor einem klassenzimmer
in dieser klasse wird englisch
unterrichtet ich öffne die tür und wir
gehen rein
die klasse bekommt heute einen neuen
deutschlehrer
da ist er schon guten tag ich bin euer
neuer deutschlehrer der lehrer erklärt
den stoff der die wiederholt bitte hier
es ist ein sehr strenger lehrer die
unterrichtung geklingelt der unterricht
ist jetzt vorbei die schülerfirmen aus
dem raum und da war unser video aus dem
kittel regierung trickse software
kowalski